alright guys so the 2014 Oscar
nominations are about to begin and
technically it's for movies that came
out in the year 2013 it's a little
confusing gotta try to keep up with it
and I'm about to watch the livestream at
8:30 in the morning on the East Coast
Here I am sitting it's 8:30 in the
morning I'm going to be reacting live to
the nominations I'm going to give you
guys my instant reactions I've done this
the past two years in a row I got a lot
of requests to do it again this year so
here I am a whole bunch of actors
producers and directors are about to
figure out of all this Oscar campaigning
and behind-the-scenes handshaking
they've been doing paid off I'm Cheryl
Boone Isaacs
president of the Academy thank you
Oh ladies and gentlemen the very
talented Chris Hemsworth
Oh the 2013 nominees for Best
Performance by an actor in a supporting
role barkhad Abdi in captain Phillips
Bradley Cooper an American hustle nice
Michael Fassbender there you go slave
Jonah Hill in the wall guys and Jared
Leto in Dallas buyers good for Best
Performance by an actress in a
supporting role the nominees are Sally
Hawkins in blue Jasmine she was good
Jennifer Lawrence in American hustle no
surprise there
the Peter and Young go in 12 years of
slow no surprise there cheers crazy
leader Roberts in august osage county
then say it and June Squibb in Nebraska
got a senior brass cap for adapted
screenplay the nominees are Richard
Linklater Louie don't be very calm walk
before midnight very calm billy-ray
for Captain Phillips nice Steve Coogan
and Jeff poke for Philomena John Ridley
for 12 years a slave and turns winter
for the wolf of water
yeah there you go thank you screenplay
the nominees are Eric Warren singer and
David O'Russell for American hustle
terrific screenplay Woody Allen for blue
Jasmine really good screenplay Craig
Morton and Melissa Wallach for Dallas
buyers club
very good Spike Jones for her very good
and Bob Nelson for Nebraska need to see
Nebraska the best animated feature film
we are pleased to nominate the Croods
chris sanders kirk demicco and christine
bells I saw Korea delayed actually
wasn't too bad with me to Spectrometer
Pierre cofán
and Chris melody Andrew Ernest and
Celestine
Benjamin Renner and Dede about that is
frozen chris buck jennifer lee and peter
della becca and the wind rock yeah I
haven't even seen it yet until she goes
I just love how Miyazaki I want to see
that so bad from Belgium the broken
right down from Ely the right Beauty
better be the hunt from Denmark the hunt
thank you from Cambodia
the missing picture blue is the warmest
color Palestine Oman
of course no blue is warmest color cuz
it's ready to NCA seventeen what a bunch
of prudes best achievement in directing
David O'Russell for American hustle good
Alfonso Cuaron program better have
Scorsese Alexander Payne for Nebraska
Steve McQueen for 12 years of sleep
better have Scorsese and Martin Scorsese
yes for the wolf of walls yes good that
makes up for the Academy making fun of
him at that screening all the nominees
are
okay best actress Amy Adams in American
hustle she was gay Blanchett in blue
jaws she was fantastic predicted that
Bullock in gravity Sandra Bullock and
gravity change in Philomena and Meryl
Streep in August Osage County of course
for Best Performance by an actor in a
leading role the nominees are Christian
Bale in American huh sighs Bruce Dern
mom in Nebraska see Nebraska Leonardo
DiCaprio thank you
Joey tell Ejiofor and 12 years of
terrific performance and Matthew
McConaughey and Dallas good job I was
really hoping they'd nominate Leo after
he got heckled and Scorsese got heckled
early we are pleased to announce that
the film selected is the Best Picture
nominees 2013 our American hustle
Charles Roven Richard suckle Megan
Alison and Jonathan Gordon producers I
would love prisoners are placed behind
the pines Phillips Scott Rudin Dana
Brunetti
but it ain't happening trust me juicers
Dallas buyers club
Robbie Bruner and Rachel winter
producers gravity alfonso cuarón and
David Heyman produces her Megan Ellison
Spike Jonze and Vincent land a producers
Nebraska
open burger and Ron Yorkshire producers
Philomena Gabriel Shanna
and tres you see with producers 12 years
of slave drug fit de gardener Jeremy
kleiner Steve McQueen and Anthony
cannabis producers and the wolf of Wall
Street yeah Emily used to be determined
very cool actually not terribly
disappointed at all with the nominations
I was really afraid that they were gonna
just snub the wolf of Wall Street
because of what happened at the Academy
screening a screenwriter got up and
heckled Martin Scorsese and said shame
on you two Leonardo DiCaprio and
Scorsese and I thought that that was
just terrible
and the Academy got a lot of bad press
for that so in some ways I'm not
surprised they nominated all those
things as well will it win probably not
who knows but I would really like it if
it did I loved American hustle I loved
the wolf of Wall Street 12 years of
slave was fantastic nice to see gravity
getting a lot of nominations by the fact
that it is a special-effects movie
that's pretty impressive of course I
knew that the place beyond the pines and
prisoners would get snubbed for
everything because it didn't come out at
the right time for the Academy members
to be concerned about it apparently but
those are two movies that are very much
deserving of Oscar nominations in my
opinion for the most part I'm actually
fairly satisfied with those nominations
for once they had the hunt in there for
foreign film they didn't have blue is
the warmest color of course because it's
nc-17 with a lot of sexual content in
there
they don't care about that kind of stuff
apparently even though it is a very good
movie I think the nominated performances
that deserve to be nominated a little
surprised to see Sandra Bullock
nominated for gravity I thought you did
a very good job in the movie but I
wouldn't really say your performance was
Oscar worthy necessarily you could
actually hear some of the audience
members chuckling when Meryl Streep was
nominated for Best Actress because if
she does a movie she gets nominated I
said in one of my videos if she looks in
a mirror in the morning she gets
nominated for an Oscar so I'm not really
that surprised there are certain things
that were not announced there I'm about
to go see if Roger Deakins isn't at
least nominated for scimitar fee for
prisoners then I'll be mad so I just
looked up Best Cinematography really
quick and yes Roger Deakins was
nominated for prisoners so I can breathe
calmly about that at least this is
actually a fairly satisfying year for me
I didn't really think of too many snubs
that's pretty cool because I didn't
think any of the films that I wanted to
get nominated like place beyond the
pines or prisoners would get nominated
so that's awesome
so guys what do you think of the
nominations let me know below guys as
always thanks so much for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck my newest